uh well
i've come with a bit of bad news as you
know everyone here has been tested for
covet
but unfortunately some of the test
results have gotten lost
so before we go on with the show we just
have to do some quick emergency testing
backstage don't worry
it's only a few people it's totally
random so when i call your name i'm just
going to need you to come with me
now
i've got a list here which i'm looking
at i have memorized but uh if you hear
your name i'm going to start with
bradley cooper
uh timothy chalamet
tyler perry uh
simulator um and wait um
javier bart dim or you're still with
penelope you know what actually
no
no no no
your your test is fine it says that
you're married i'm negative negative
will smith um
you're married but you know what you're
on the list and looks like jada approved
you so you get on up here
get on your feet
all right
now i see we've got another bad boy on
our list let's see uh is that uh
jacob ellardy is that how you say it a
lordy
i've seen you on euphoria and yes you
are legal i'm sorry
you are
positive so you're gonna
you're gonna need a deep pcr test now
no no i don't i don't want any of you
all to worry you know it's gonna be a
typical quick covert test you'll come
backstage take your mask off if you have
one
and your clothes and then i'm gonna swap
no it's simple i'm gonna swab the back
of your mouth with my tongue and
we're just gonna do some other freaky
stuff which i will record for
academy protocol really this isn't up to
me you know the truth is we're just
we're still in a pandemic
uh oh boy
one more name on the list
so uh denzel pauletta is a is john david
here um no no
i'll i'll make a house call it's fine
there's no need to worry uh there will
be more names i'll see you guys at the
back in backstage but right now i would
you can go back there i'll be waiting
for you um
please welcome jason momoa and josh
brolin
you